[拍手]
ございません
den o data
何雑なんだよフェアリーそんなボールも消えてもられて
持っての若者外れるようないやあんまために食べればいいのです
パフォーマンそうします
なので
えーみなさんとか暖かい目で見てもらえたらなと思います
インスタイルフットボール何だかわからないと思いますセレクトやんまいないと思うん
ですよだからちょっとです
いいいる1ボールというのが夏バテの紹介剥製いただきたいと思います
いいボールを持ってきて何するんだっていうのはなんとなく想像の通りいます是非言っ
てみたかってるよ
こんな感じで
色数ことなくて
だけじゃなくて
なんか日本の方があるんですよね例えばこんな風に
足の上でボールをピタリと止めたりあとは
こんなふうにお礼を挟んで埋め猿とか
様微妙ですか
8もっとかっこいい形で抵抗と思います
まずは一つ目越冬
ジャンプしながらコールまできますいきます水2
わっ
ありがとねー
明日パケ
ジャガーとすごいやっていきます今度はフォールの周りを足が1周振ってもあります
一瞬です
ふぇいとぅわっっ
えっ
もうちょっといいかんって思いますうんうん
ふぇいってんがっ
あーまぁこんな感じでありがとうございます
まあこれからだったらなんかサッカー選手がやった事はあるのかね
a 見たことあると思うんですよ
でフリペるってボールが全然こんなもんじゃなくてじゃあ皆さんや叩かなくして
くださっているので
東海とかで使うようなすごい技もう今の3倍くらいと扱いやすい
やっているか
山行きなく
聖五運わっっ
という感じでまあグリッターリップフォーレまあし使う
足使ってもいろいろあるけどまぁ他にも色んなことがあるのでまぁちょっと
今日も母もしゃべれないんだパフォーマンス2本用意してきています
まず13名ちょっといきなりえーすごいから待ってるのもはや大変なのでちょっとゴー
ミンが集まったらカレーパフォーマンスにフェンちょっとおっおっお付き合い下さり
ざー次の曲お願いします
まあねここまでおり甍覆違って風も話したくなかったと思いますね
ちょっと休憩だからある工夫
あるかなかなかなかったらな
[音楽]
ああああああ
ええええええ
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
[音楽]
の母のありがとうございますめちゃくちゃや利益
でたこの2時
見たとおり結構狭いんですよねこんなとこでやるんだって感じだと思うよ
ほんとよく市場
12番目にてばいい
皆さんめっちゃ硬いんでそんなこと関係なくて本当
をとってもやりやすいですねありがとうございます
で
まぁちょっと
まぁ一応
スピーチしてってことなのでまあパフォーマンスだけじゃなくてちょっと大
借家的にちょっとしゃべろうと思っています
エットっ
でこのクリスタルすぐ北みんなパンティあったんですけど
普段は大会とか出てますね
ローン
さっき社会してもらったかもしれないですけど一応日本代表で
せ音の世界にまで行けて
8そんな感じで日本を出し独占して頑張っています
で再開って言われてもどうやって勝敗決めんだって感じだと思うけどだったかなって
感じだと思うよ
こんなのに何かページで一人で去ってお客さんにパフォーマンて見てるんじゃなくて
最高ではいっぱい1ですパターンですね
一体一度ええまあ大好きな三分で
まあ誕生日を3回出て1人1分半でまた違ったりするんですけど
ずっと空って庄八麺のプレイんですよね
they どうやって決めるかっていうと思う
うーんちゃっ違うにいて
入った1例
こっちついてみたいな感じでくれるよ印象材緩衝液なんですよ
ここがちょっと話し声とかねぇ
例えば普通のなんかスポーツとかだったらまた例えば
合うそうと稼ぎが増えたとかピントあるじゃないか全部へ
でもこれ不倫たり宝転生ないんですよ
そこが面白いところであえて
剪定とか
[音楽]
ん
まあ頭とか混じってるとか判断して言ってたりこっちでしょみたいな
天井出てたらもっと違ってってあるじゃないですか
そうじゃなくて
なーんかジャッジのあーなんか安静か炙って
パーカペパボ'パティンコにキュン
でい
最初はそういうふうに
大体の招致待っていなかったのでよだいたい
すごい技やすくやったら勝ち森2-40
ものすごい馬鹿やったもん勝ちで
やっぱさんのいけどもその頃って
まあありなんかこうやっていろんな人に見えてもらえたり
しなかったんですよ僕自身もこういうなんか遠いはばかりパケ目指してお客さんで中
なんとかも山まで受けは来なくて
まあば療育の却下にいてもらえることってなかったんですけど
でも弾番頭ああ
こういうふうにその札幌とかまぁだいたい教師 ever ジャッジの心と感性とか
いうだけでなくソーラーアプローチの仕方がどんどん発展してきて
hey
僕もそれ見てもう
あのー
一杯をされて
自分のたから慢性一般の方をちゃんと動かくるようなパフォーマンスっていうのを
目指して
技術もそうですけどまあそういう心と火の帝分も
一緒に未来てシェイプアップやってきて
やっぱしたらだんだんとまぁ大会とかでも勝てるようになったし
またパフォーマンスでもお客さんに続いて多くのお客さんに観てもらうようになって
ねええええ
東口にはサーキットよねもう本当に向かい再開まで入れたりとかして
本当に
[音楽]
ブーバーれっウォッチャー1になかったのでもうちょっと珍しいけどもうちょいちょい
パパですよ
ている
ブーブー5試合加えカーぬーっにだけど
あったりとかん
レベルになって
で本当にありがたい限りです
でまぁなんか回出勤何か言いたげるって言うとあの本
そうやって皆さんがあの本当に素晴らしいアイディアとか技術とかあのさと思ってなん
か査定
が技術とかも大事ですけどまぁ一人と負けるかというところも進めていくとよりその
人を動かす動かす巻き込めて a ムーブメントが
を起こせるように
なる可能性があると思うんですよねってすごく単純な話です
それだけです皆さんが違って素晴らしい技術タイルを持って人の心を動かす
ムーブメントっていうのをやっていく形を僕はいたいなと思っています
って感じれば僕のあんま面白くない話そろそろ終わりたいと思うので最後に
まあ日本武道館とか東京モーターショーとか
3番組中で行ってきた僕が一番ドキドキのパフォーマンス
最後にさん変換見ていただきたいと思いますお付き合い願いますシアター
最後に下さいお願いします
[音楽]
[拍手]
ん
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
ああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]